this is a production of Cornell
University
good morning everyone
and the bill said if you have a long
drive program
hence they got an entire constellation
33 mass but I'm furthest to step in by
my hair to further forward
one of the first thing he did was add a
brand for any product in addition to the
anti-fraud are a remington tainted from
the unaccountable what do we send them
an application or they choose what label
up so very well during the program from
the flyer with you this is what it looks
like a captain Denny MIMO drive big man
but the pinata pictures actually from
2014 and numbers of entries fluctuating
in our burger I think our teeth was
about 2011 we had 1,300 right and this
area have to be of you 1600 drives so
are they putting more companies to come
in
well get to control that too much I can
why didn't we detach my glasses
California but in this case was the
rockers he predetermined prior to our
arrival at that moment this is an error
shot
Paula sighs the color quality on it
because it was taken by a drone so what
the Pens they run weeks Graham's on
Saturday al back the air and certainly
not freedom Andrew put a quality and but
we also run satellite play for exaple
active site and Hershey garden is the
oldest of our black explain to you
privately grant air pretty boring staff
and the master barbers ways are
instrumental in hearing sound so they're
easy running up that means 19 right
subset of our version by the way we have
about 950 right again this year
one of the little a single ring and
we'll give them all funds because plant
died with their deep brown gravy and
we're good at that
we have fluctuated in September
what that wasn't I am this one year and
I thought the morality of silver blaze a
job my audience I beautiful
Russians are not hardened Siberia they
go there to Miami see very lovely the
well look at the brown we also do a
subset the biography that his everyday
men hello they polish and posted at the
Larsen Research Forum and that's a huge
property and majors but a brilliant
three days in order typically 20,000
visitors and this yet last year I was
alive when that regardeth value any
playing on our program and they have
this is the three thousand acre park
there's a fun there's a partner with red
circle is inspector there the area
movies again we're doing a grand testing
all three of
nice comparison to the largely container
for this planter at FEMA which stands
for Baptist agriculture researchers he
was alive last this is your nap and I
didn't print any favorite hobby but it
is our web page
all this data is up there all you have
to do the Greek word anyway click on the
topic result and you're looking for all
the hallmarks of women triggering come
up number of how many connections
grading button in the Miranda top to
bottom so is the viewer information at
little more comprehensive national
probably which we also painted if you
click on a picture they be a scores and
comment that were rendered very nice
Austria and a number of rehab operators
really you're thinking man to this is
their hobby Pennsylvania and we have
some of the planes that broke the honors
and then neighbors and friends come out
and I'll take a poll let's go to guard
sense of ours we also have berger sales
will show up and bring people quiet and
they're writing orders right here in
abroad with that makes it really paper
industry and light would be helpful to
see well that's what I hold I talk about
the operating to let's get into that and
we have over 63 tablet Otis in the
program this year and these are some of
the ones that are left and these pop
scores of these lon
first rate to remember we could change
this as we go forward we'll have scores
admission standing of this plan but this
is the first reading it was conducted
between July 2 and July 15 and it does
make it out to week to do a grading
because in 33 hours are in the gloom
maybe probably waiting this line was
really exciting Da Capo right Mountain
see and I know that an active Agassi
consumers
praxis immoderation
a number people to lose very well and I
only show any plan to receive it woody
- you know school here today so that
could hotline with one people today all
the way up to five the perfect score so
there's superb elderly and courses to
develop the proven winners introduction
they are quite itis they have wonderful
i imitated as well as the hostess nine
flight and Lena did exceptionally well
in first grade and they had a lot of
blue bullier quality proper or
programmatic second so that date back
he's five this is funny hope they had
built healed Omid what is it is a sport
and you get a lot of sport and
horticulture back in the 1890s quite a
number of chrysanthemum besides bra that
wraps the sport
the yellow one of those of the white
rains from that they cut that off
propagated
we called through the winter 2000 that
they do is the propagation some
conservative attorney visits
intellectual property that is lost to
the civilian company we have contractors
that are gonna state that directly in
the contract so the one Anita I get
anyone where the bio legal point but a
[ __ ] they very good for if you know
that they have more dirty plant come out
of him let them not keen fan that of his
act and attracted white flowers away
Martin warranty what Louie a library
wire so that cycle and some of the other
one visa both rulers plan on grandpa's
strength and super Belfield also
inverter different worth and we had some
passed upon bread on one last year at
the top 10 percent plan it will be
working in this year conservative lovely
and the reason for that is we
continually have had with Alternaria
from the in the convenience talented
poet focuses on different tackle large
number think we can eradicate if you
remember you know your disease triangle
if you can bring one of those legs you
can check these laws but
in a common area of infectious materials
all these presidents late and when you
get to that period straight about now
some of the cities aside Rock a lot of
these and spray a fungicide 50 pediment
and the show secret phonetic who
vanishes so the show is actually hybrids
we have a code of opinion and they're
particularly strongly oppose the rich of
my adult Odyssey to developing wonderful
under the plan so the other bikini
variety and you know until it actually
is market share because while the names
of the different really sold understand
offices as we have happened
the forgetting to some of the top in
part in the broker a little overwhelmed
a lot of growers on inside he can't be
bought
consumption hunters over what but let me
come back and repeat your business to
the site and you painted a to do an easy
selection on so easy wave their
companion Venus baited and they're
extremely nice they had a good blue
polity and they also have intriguing
color the engineer is one of our
long-term
program and very pleased with what they
bring to the briefing brought barriers
experience and how family is a
distracting variety new alleged to the
federal gold cigarette tag and sometimes
the company will say new plot but they
excited to listen here before I remember
something to try that way so when it
actually showed a new planet and state
acceptable children that I have visitors
Austin's of artists factory mark says
that a lot and equation
ecology and followed by awesome food and
interns looted and is a beautiful
passage purple diamond I thought that
beautiful and certain perform very well
so looking good today
three weeks after the first reading so
so about I did look back on a record and
native center that we had over a hundred
days in Greece Romania in 2010-2011 and
now the man would be working with this
resplendent passed away
big Lawson horticulture and one of our
friends property sure so that at least
would have been with all the material in
there is a memorial for that season turn
but anyway
and again dinners on a different tact
and they're going in and doing about 20
to 30 varieties for that site and we
back all of their material is pretty
aggressive and of course we have
participation communities our second
food plan submitted program so here's
son panini on road and prices guide of
bridges plant long blooming lot flower
and son being a little bit more trailing
of suprises cycles or top right policies
but those are big nose and we have over
three years running over 36 firm the
entrance program limit for 180 plant
others in deployables all our biggest
contributors we have
all in all the subsidies permutations a
person article ribbon company millions
from management a lot of things from
them and this success road and after
publishing a unique explanation that
they're doing online but anyway this is
the strong performer where they honest
Illustrated a success yellow will hire
flower entity the little one actress
fitted the line so my to see finally
grant a seriously though this is
seriously doesn't look at always a
pharmacist and but need is a good life
has a very different view the draft even
as we go forward
southern plant that are really really
strong and a number of these magnets in
a swanky roads like violet and what's
that etcetera that this very way they
need to alter like that stronger this is
our major difficulty with the Austin
area blood abuse new one to us blanket
blue star and very strong with warmer
ovation white from Fiedler
as a painter to the number of pi
including the 15 apartment and see from
this picture this is a very very strong
woman
Edward criminally receivers in law and
breeder to sales people below the other
firms come is that it's so hard
repeat that Super Duty especially in
mid-may and I sure enjoyed us the
creative her family Atlanta still very
humid every morning to wake up balance a
committee and then by the time the
community of do hot drop ended up 50%
and that firm strong black us does the
employment yet fifty percent in any
means that you are so while everything's
pretty California ass program when you
bring it back our position here things
are a little different that's why a lot
of companies landfill area for all
visitors Europe yet also from that nine
states surrounding and why that's the
lion share of the population and yeah
sometimes I kinda wondered at me I think
why they chose that one the team are
keen was busy but it is only later music
and being at a personal
maybe they're not quite as appearances
would be any but they have stated and
that is more suited being they're all
good probably the best selling of
opinion Lang sentimentality this moment
and I used to drive a drive out 30
minutes from work to this
experimentation and go along while I
like in our daily report and account
number of this both of you PM group now
I say market charity single that land
nothing other things like Brandis y'all
know about pregnancy had list come
atmosphere and send from reaction one
said yeah she had a cross word room said
was years ago and about American hockey
not their plan another really nice long
trilogy bread out there researching in a
program we had pronoun so then GMO
plants marketed and or distributed need
to have registrations
with USDA not so guys villains
very capable lot autism drains nation to
the key fact lab discovered it go back
to the orgy
well Douglas lead that would be a
logical process or create issues
concerns of our art plans of eight words
but with legal matters who argued that
as you on that we are under all his
survive and so he is parted after work
right by of lucky the list came out a
time to come enjoy music pink with over
sixty right how hard the big reason had
to throw away all times prophecy written
in that form another group has been
showing the real promise aside secrecy
is aesthetic fear that I stick to those
from Syngenta and I like in Texas Brock
there
most of them are in strong but he
staggered and Withings Erdogan being
conservative and looking like a very
little public hopefully give a second
thought
classified a little smaller come to our
opinion but they're a good apartment 11
years back a white during this load room
and the music birds are all of the able
needed or sleep that they divine be very
well or that in one respect he had mild
and certain and here at and seemed that
the beetle the data field big painting
that lasting cheaper to live and have
since present life so you're selling
black Athenians or sultana's or urban
landscape survive but they're going to
go in areas where certain present or
private you wind up with unbeaten and
and I dreadfully had the very
any artillery any ethical Department to
Java that is here by accident ever our
sweet pea slipping like Swiss cheese
with the abeyance is not acceptable
well having been at background
information these two gay men builded
have Latin so we power on the action
climbing variety that you have here torn
up but really only market share when is
a beautiful mix invaders with lease
their art appropriate pain or any plant
they're growing out there that this all
reality my by the fact very instruction
is actually the all the qualities of
variety very well for rare one point
with the lowest score that work 167 and
but he denied any of these something
else's I didn't want actually provided
out for you
[Music]
propinquity
I ran across a little bird theory to be
mayor
these design containers and this is the
plot and right now he's plant is so
loaded through I can't believe it the
probably is to portal plan I should say
they are close to come from February
through April sometimes we learn this is
a mature had entry shut up in bed they
all one for an active spot and then
replace three four and a half a box of
this body outer layers in contrast this
helps us standardize things going into
the problem little birdies and they
preferred this canary this Red Robin
support and that cute but four
containers on back or happy or about
what they not have to worry about within
his plant blowing over it you some power
Brian three people about that we had
done of the Sun versions of three
winners and I saw one at color
how fortunate
we're not seen but I love this 11 which
is a strong grower and also nice color
pictures of the livers I should've shot
it on fire unit I mean with his desert
name this plant has been with us for a
number of years every year had a very
high school always mine down to 10% and
boggles my mind it's true blue the
lovely power and that kind of rare say
back horticultural cultivars that are
really blue and there aren't that many
matters that's that's it well they for
men's ears they want a farm in any way
here in I love I felt a very strong
bloomer brought by the time we get in
office typically things the cover the
flowers won't give people Sheila does
beaten fertile so I've seen places where
it's Groundhog Day well and the blue
versus compromising edition one of my
favorite American hockey entrances is
known fully intact
hold that they had perfect adda me in
that really well throughout season and
also have the beautiful gold ha so very
forever very for the stronger corner and
we did it American you want to see
marital religious oven down Arboretum
they talk about 100 finished oligarchs
in their proper we hit two three four
depending on here this one can see the
business wall but at very strong bloom
may color is called see across the
bargain but I had as well so recommended
Harlan we do get a lot of combinations
and obviously that's this year the ad
and son doesn't do so well worth of this
new great and we wind up with plans that
are three everything eaten plain Isis
grab see where did you have three
different species sometimes one Michael
Feazell
at ember pretty much gone these are inch
centavos
we had probably 20 he ended this year
last year 30 or 35 and here's one that
is not really new seen this before in
the perfect last year for the meta but
good work and actually for us usually we
fill this Barlow guillotine but any
comedy to be nice that were
experimenting why happens what we be
doing very go to survive will get up to
a hundred forty three entries in this
container and awesome that there are
black plastic is what hot try growing
will be in white-hot one year we got
within third bubble temperature razor in
the sand that family and we went up with
savory not good it anyway the night
Pompey love the color combination a
Halton was the claim fairly could score
there's no sort of like it this is
another one activity Marquis month
matrix and what the mom shows when I eat
that but anyway a that preferences
hey way strong before the word very few
years ago for those of you to stand off
and I ain't that always a dream you see
how much different State Park and an
impacted the same culpable often ain't
that be better
why they're not sitting on Garcon Laurie
all that a merry way when she brought
that back you're getting the board's
reasoning to help the common taxi on the
glass well I always well II this be
theta degree where his Dustin's and
their great fire fire longtime nightmare
people are what happens throughout very
any sight and the paint but often blows
over
whereas beta is positive that my record
personally is for very loud message
doing something really light may be
happy
operating on every windows bought both
of these very plant in current size of
your market identity to it and we
actually grows long saying water at some
of the deeper super moderated school
degree now they were
wrong I wasn't approved cultivars do you
think like this receiving plant and the
other standing activity got food some
people collect the knack a couple years
ago at supertunia plenty from proven
winners and opinion Indian Summerford an
understanding era will award under
hundred he favored I had and my first
year for San Jose update so often coming
license of the three winners getting and
opportunities change the name lineup
would say cult or how does that work
back off both burn fat but from vision
perspective he said what we had number
burgers of years but more common mutant
jabu that all they produce they have
potted arises haha requires a barber I
live work and he subpoenas way out of
Houston off this one in with last year's
very well with great man who did a blue
burger Bertha Mason here's another one
bourbon sweet love for found again and
the from Warrington public platform
supporters verbena had about 40 good
routine of ours and our programs here
were all on my Bible words he is back at
grown higher the Penn State Extension on
fire today on the anyway who was
remarkably estimated Raveena's sessions
in this year film degree this is from
Zulueta and a very strong color all the
rock garden diseases with often repeated
cycle with a very strong period
production of flowers in history
everyone that is a good one and interest
rates the ball always most of the very
strong in Veritate bread probably best
that our last year in period lap 70 feet
will over 95 degrees and set down a lot
for being upset my intern after the
garden that I wish you to cut back one
of these fries let's see if they come
back with one kid back there isn't this
the brothers were kind of active or
being yeah I cleaned them up and they
look a little tight she may not be very
much do they include the ever son can
give another good song colors awful
warmer and super being a cherry person
he W black ruinous color there too and
it's very important we had a number of
antennas they do very wrong program
until the apology or is that after wait
and then a white has a lot of scenes
that so they're teenage cultivar that
involve Oh Dudley Sarah this is one of
luma five road and it's terrible that
because this is salsa or missus laugh
will gap there their garden and she
multipliers off John sniffing this way
that peak is one hand and one play
soccer everybody my crazy effect out
they don't have eyes do so my program
and try not to do a lot of Holly body or
may need of the plan this is one is the
very well for 32 so a blue light and
receipts superior Radian per straight
but dealt with very well last year at
the compact variety colors brought and
his hobbies but we have hundreds of tons
of skippers out there you've got solvers
that I swallow tail all kind of
beneficial track they're playing when in
the vicinity that were claimed by
disease this year losing for was a very
large cloud of our slaves
but that is all this man and first time
I didn't think like I was so delighted
our games living very well looks like we
did before and certainly here's another
one this cultivar also come their way of
life another form of an Athenian path
that I am too tall so every in that
support plan removing very useful in
their operation that will appear being
anti problem is located usually they
have as well be right but that very
short a suit of hierarchy would be this
year but if we want to place the bread
all gooey and very strong bloomers got a
brain for looking flower but they can be
cut black hole and also have a very long
period with either than that there lotta
many women in our program
some people look alive he's a plan to
the develop after third one and three
versus three final animation and where
he is he that all deities they are not
either maybe backward in south axis but
he didn't want to get oil nectar as
anyone's
they stacked real and the most North
American species existed wait
I'm in switchover we had a little issue
with my computer so I'm going to go into
another series of flies here all right
so the phonies I have you seen before
but now one very attention to this
particular opinion this is a sensation
we first did even all merit selection
award important greater damage once a
traitor
are we actually to be that we had better
sniffers and die and secondarily one
second one requires the presidential
party half
probably done but yet it had a serious
importance of usability and I ran to why
the people if they see the power and the
power button painted battlefield some of
the others realized for dinner will be
on that strong market hall but whatever
they wanted to get to the chef
this is something that we saw on
California and Tenant retreat continued
to attention to it immediately
I said wow it's a double duty and what
you're seeing there is it actually sort
of really put into the fire again over
there several cultivars to be happy
this one is pretty much the strongest
Wildman plus a so-called player bill for
that patient of large component of the
program manifested as one shade here one
book collection distributed isone color
of the variety had bigger flowers of
Latin ordinary plant others had a lot
small platter when to plant 300 color
ribbon but these pieces may want and
Alton Walker the Bremen spirited ready
serious energy and leaf element part but
they often have it that plantation don't
go
I only want to breathe last year you
have it in Calais including the popular
standing up at work four and a half feet
the clinical result whether they really
sweat and examine problem tonight
deposited worried and were the Angley
one on top readers as that brought the
dozen patients really good grower and
there's not a hundred recruit baloney
this is Theodora and Loretta had a
really strong color to it is close-up of
that and then were spat they have
neither collected in truth and then it
is flowers a nickel on their gentleness
in a promotional video of about 87 plant
sitting area to see cadre of wall
faculty commercial will blast this earth
in the life support
insert the rain watch the plant
rehydrating from that full glory of
anniversary time that's what meaning
back for began but director flower power
plant if you obviously have one ward
three years ago refine a habit and pop
consenting to that sticker on the year
they attended bright world very strong
lovely plant and this beautiful dude
came ahead and pair that right there big
flower first from growers
- warpath here's my grows and deeper
look at Lawrence plant there's nothing
to blame her either on when our that
before the on top and I'm delighted to
say they only had one apart they had the
problems here what a strong focus you
would have Oscars and container
explaining these things are great
components or just a radical package
that put your right foot in there or
maybe solar power but they're really
strong color they entered three white
forms this one of my favorite the
Umbreon hatred beyond the important Wow
holy equality and projected realism and
tearing existence of what other pooja
look at my beautiful music of life with
that so we'll see wanted there's your
mail offered and son of the mailbox and
walkers destiny funny shape and Sun blue
more sentence and see planter will be
the penguin had my fault
beautifully in all conditions lockers
and a lot oh yes through the winters
perhaps in this year's well for three
buzz of the others but actual equanimity
all the word members online 46 men and I
always healthy I'm so grateful to be 18
every environment but they all agree
these are the best plant-based Sundays
on market so they're ridiculous
anyway sir fire road other one this is
on PW that pink variety and have
survived and go on with it
yes and again resemble his other
cultivars spirits on the remaining human
nation but that has business anymore
culture vicinity some totally want that
we probably one of those introductions
Hillary will not be enacted so it's a
really good opportunity to check that
the positive the great job they're
making fun active not really advocating
the Post Road wallet and I understand
our bridges working on developing he
listened to the watery hi correct the
customers low in the nursery operation
but Martha's plant they were
in fact for the meantime would be very
beautiful these viruses coming back and
this is a camp right arm other one of
these not gorgeous beautiful flower on
the side of the body but this is my
favorite clothing made at my pastel
color track make my waiting for arguing
that flower color pieces Arab or art
practice she knows the rich song by her
father my wife team reservist
traditional refers back now the fun is
accessible yet there's Chloe all the
word see her tonight is my apricot
variety she gave a great flower side
he'll tractor we do have a number angel
wing I love this one it's a little
harder to his picture business what live
fact sheet up somebody hold the bottom
here but any has a very good plan like a
degree for training because I had
wonderful follow oh well they have
running club began with my
I thank you all very much for attention
and encourage you to not listen to the
Penn State fire products some hand you
can go to be up in the apology for the
Chanticleer and that's how the once told
me there's more panic Barnes ratings
will help ease that much water retention
and
on my own beans shall drop Romano softly
well they have sony like they are here
like me like me do and I think the
bigger work we've got an area mature but
what would have had sporadic green we've
got over 1.4 1.6 or changes and that
creates a prior injury then so I'll keep
my eye on black brought that way up
remember what they relax is to say that
I want to open my later at 5:30 Anna do
that walk walk walk all day in wires all
home very good archives are daily I had
a child but that part or not that lovely
to the north of my position
I'll have and they're very good I
wouldn't consider myself a flavor expert
but I take a little birdie they go along
salad in his trial gardens yes you are
naughty you say I people who reflect the
oven right away yeah just do that take
our crop of this to Google it's right
there any of her name writing less
accessible to subject for better weather
than dirt eight sorry good hands back
and there's some of the lanai there's a
1/2 number years ago they bought an
aversive subsequent generational plant
presidenting probably not as strong as
the purple threads or the green light
green power that that meant was you have
accuracy with the penetration was
leather
[Music]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu